[Music]
what i might it doesn't say on the
prompter what is it is my name bruce
well i don't know what your name was i
rely on the prompter too all right we'll
figure that out we'll we'll ask someone
in the back what was your favorite part
of you know id at xbox are you asking me
the prompter doesn't say ask you oh
that's true it says chat what was your
favorite what was your favorite part
chad you tell us what your favorite part
was because we'd love to know uh my
favorite part was watching uh tech and
andrea watching them the dynamics i was
here for you know bye-bye neighbor
yeah i had to i tackled it was like
hello neighbor no more like bye-bye
neighbor you know um thirsty suitor that
was interesting
is great chat i know what chat's gonna
say chad's gonna say cuphead yeah there
it is i knew it they're gonna i knew
they were gonna say cuphead so uh
cuphead was their favorite and cuphead
feels like i'm uh it's a nightmare to me
because if i stream it i'm just gonna
get backseated into oblivion so i
thought you're gonna be raging that
platforming is real
absolutely i don't know platforming rage
that that just sounds like you just said
you don't rage quit earlier today i
never do
let's we got to look at the schedule
that's what the teleprompter says look
at the schedule all right so we are just
about to see the saber interactive's uh
presentation should have evil dead the
game should have space marine 2 in there
maybe something from painkiller then we
got loot goblins which is always a good
time i just don't know what that time is
going to be all right it's going to be
all lou goblins i'm really looking
forward to seeing what it is devolver
public access at 4 20 p.m then of course
5 p.m the chats choice awards where you
all the all the people we're talking to
right now get to choose all the games of
the year the best action adventure the
best sim
every category in the game awards but
you're picking this time
so chat we are giving you i got to read
that i always forget we're giving you a
behind-the-scenes look today before they
go live with the chat's choice awards we
don't know who's hosting uh this is the
teleprompter area obviously we read off
all the things they want us to say
as you can see here my next line is
i'm not going to say that
you have to read the prompt i'll read it
gosh and biscuits cup chapa
i sure can't wait to vote for game of
the year we'll scroll up again
what does that mean let's say knock up a
little more we have to read this gosh
and biscuits choppa
so that's the dress is that me nick we
need to scroll it we need oh you're
gonna you're gonna change it okay
thank you very much okay um
uh actually and this by the way this is
nicholas operating the teleprompter back
here uh we need to make a quick change
uh that's not something i would ever say
gosh biscuits so can you go back and
actually change that as well
i'm still sitting in chapman wait uh i
need you to change it to the f word over
and over can you just put the f word
over and over thank you very much f
that's how i over and over that's how i
would talk yeah except except
all right what's next
uh there you go
all right bruce you always do this you
you never stay on screen i want it to
sound natural cup i gotta
can you just so can we change again
scroll up we change what is c channel
why am i go no go up it said ch1 why am
i channel one upper
channel one star
look next we know nick's this isn't
nick's fault okay script writer's fault
i'm reading my line before you change
those too next up is the saber
interactive the developer that brought
halo master chief collection the pc and
the witcher 3 wild hunt to nintendo
switch they've released multiple world
war z absolutely those games yeah gay
and aftermath they're currently
developing a multiplayer horror game
based on the evil dead film franchise
and also a single-player game based on a
quiet place and now here's our
presentation from sabre interactive
[Music]
[Music]
hello and welcome to the saber
interactive 2021 showcase my name is tim
willits chief creative officer at sabre
we are excited today to bring you some
new world premiere game announcements
along with a bunch of updates and
reveals on some of our upcoming titles
for next year you may know saber from
our development work over the past 20
years and for some of our recent hits
like world war z and snow runner or our
history of bringing games like the
witcher 3 to switch we've been growing a
lot in the last year since joining the
embracer family and we are now proud to
boast 19 development studios around the
world
studios such as 4a makers of the metro
series new world interactive the studio
behind insurgency sandstorm aspire media
who rocked the world earlier this year
with the announcement of their knights
of the old republic remake and many more
great studios as a publisher we have
been growing quickly and today we will
share with you what to look forward to
from the saber label of games in the
upcoming year last fall we released
world war z aftermath a huge new
expansion and evolution of the world war
z zombie shooter series with story
episodes set in rome and the russian far
east next year we'll be releasing native
playstation 5 and xbox series x versions
this update will be free for owners of
world war z aftermath
the update will also include a new game
mode called horde mode xl
now
if you like horde modes this is truly
exciting we have hundreds of more
zombies more than you've ever seen on
the screen before so look for more
information about horde mode xl next
year stay tuned also in the new year for
a first look at another of our upcoming
horror titles a quiet place a quiet
place is being developed by electrica an
incredible studio in montreal and is an
original single-player story-driven game
set in the same universe as the movies
you'll need to use your ingenuity in
your wits to outlast the relentless
death angels
you are about to see three world
premiere game announcements with reveal
trailers
now these three games represent the
various tastes of saber so
they're not just horror games you have
two racing games that are worlds apart
and something completely different
a game set in alternate history
steampunk victorian london but first we
have a special treat for our evil dead
fans who are looking forward to our
upcoming groovy horror action title
evil dead the game
last week i had a chance to have a very
special chat with my good friend the
game awards own jeff keely and the
horror icon himself bruce campbell who
is reprising his role as every
generation of ash williams in the evil
dead the game
check out that chat followed by all our
game reveals and announcements now
[Music]
all right this is something special i'm
joined now by tim willits from saber and
the one and only bruce campbell bruce uh
it is so exciting that evil dead is back
as a video game we got to uh world
premiere this last year at the game
awards and now it's awesome to be
sharing more news uh with fans but i
gotta ask you and believe me i i loved
you were even narrating some of the
videos we saw this year about this game
you are all in uh
i'm curious like what made you want to
come back for for evil dead in this form
because it's about the only form i can
come back in uh i i hung up my jersey as
ash hung up the chainsaw because i can't
physically do that crap anymore you know
i'm like an old stunt guy my voice is
fine though you know my voice is what
gives me away these days i'm at a
restaurant blah blah some guy will go
hey i heard your voice doesn't they
don't recognize me but they recognize my
voice so uh i figured let's let's stay
involved in this game i i love the evil
dead movies that got me into the film
business
so game on game on is right uh tim i
know saber has expanded doing more
things and more studios this was a
project that was was close to your heart
and certainly i think inspired some of
the work you you did back in the day it
did right oh yes yes i mean we've been
big fans of the franchise in these
movies for years and uh you know when
when ash held that shotgun in the
earlier movies that was an inspiration
for uh for a lot of the games that i've
done the last uh 30 years bruce when
they first pitched you on this what was
that like how did you find out about
this project uh well i'm one of the
producers of the movies so i'm i'm in on
the
the drill
uh we knew it was time for another game
we had done three other games evil dead
games years ago
they were kind of much more rudimentary
but they got better and then now we can
swim with the sharks we can run with the
big dog
yeah tim uh for people that that haven't
heard an update in a while how's
development going on the game
development's going well you know we are
in the home stretch you know what's
what's really exciting about this game
is you know it has so many different
aspects to it you got your asymmetrical
pvp you can play with your friends and
we even have a couple side missions
where you can play by yourself so we're
adding a lot of content you know we
really think that we can deliver kind of
that full featured evil dead experience
to to our fans that love the franchise
so we're really excited about it and
we'll talk more specifics uh soon as
well i think the the end result is going
to be it's worth the wait that's that's
my goal is that a was worth the wait
b it was worth it to play it period
bruce i know one of the cool things in
this game is that there are four
different ashes uh in there from four
different eras which one would you main
which uh which which character do you
think people should play with oh i would
do the old guy he's got all the
experience
a young guy doesn't know his ass from a
hole in the ground but that's the cool
thing about the game you can play other
characters you can play possessed ash so
it it really is whatever your mood is
when you play correctly around but when
you went into the video booth did you
have to do all all these versions of ash
of course you know that's the nightmare
of doing voices for games you have to
allow for some guys going to stand at a
window and go click click
click click it's like get away from the
window there's nothing there and the
characters get killed
47 different ways you have to do every
death so yeah it's the roots of a tree
you know when you watch a video game
it's a lot of work tim when you guys
were scoping out this game and what was
most important for you to make sure that
was was in this so the most important
thing for us was to really get that
action you know the the evil dead movies
are about the gory kills and the
finishing moves and you know i love my
finishing moves uh so um you know really
kind of delivering that impact one thing
to add about the different ashes when
you pick your ash he'll fall into a
different category of class you have
your leader which is the old ash your
warriors your hunters and your support
so based on the ash that you pick you
will you will have a different uh basic
kind of class where you can help your uh
your team win let's talk about some of
the other characters uh what can we
expect bruce uh from from the evil dead
uh cannon uh is pretty much everything
in there uh there's a lot man let me
tell you you know we went back to some
of the original evil dead cast members
to get their voice in on because the
hardcore true blue
folks if they hear that it's the real
scottie and the real
cheryl it just gives the game that much
more street cred instead of some guy
who's trying to sound like somebody else
said oh it sounds bogus that's how much
we love our fans is that you know you go
that extra mile for them so that they'll
shut up
yeah no seems seems very authentic and
as you said tim the action i mean when i
first saw this trailer uh it felt very
modern very up to date and given you
know
your lineage tim are doing some amazing
you know action games inspired by evil
dead it's great to kind of go back to
the the core of it and the you know
multiplayer is obviously gonna be a big
part of it as well um speaking of
multiplayer bruce i understand your son
is a twitch streamer is that right yeah
andy campbell he uh
you know i tell him i don't understand
what he does but i don't have to because
he's a gamer he knows what's going on uh
hopefully we're going to set up some
tutorials with the old man
i mean i don't know anything so this is
going to be it'll be a real test of his
skills
he's excited to play it as well so
hopefully finally i can kick my son's
ass at something i was going to say new
new twitch content playing uh evil dead
but that's part of the fun now is that
you know
games are really taking over the world
um and for someone like you bruce that
you know has done some game stuff you
continue to do awesome film stuff you
got your new film black friday i'm
curious like when you look at the gaming
space even through the eyes of your son
are you excited about kind of the
opportunity there uh yeah because it's a
real game
you know uh we did games before but i i
just don't think they were
they were mainstream ready and and these
really are the atmospheres are
incredible night day
rain
snow
you know for a horror movie the tone is
important the environment is important
the atmosphere a lot of people did his
mood and they've done a good job at
capturing it the tricky thing taking a
movie putting it into a video game but
it's a pretty good fit and i think it
works well yeah no uh the guys that
saber i've done an awesome job every
time i see it i get more and more
excited to actually jump in and play it
uh
tim before we go uh i mean what's it
been like for you guys to work with
bruce i mean this you kind of can't do
this game without bruce right
uh yes yes you know this uh it's been a
pleasure uh to work with bruce and this
also just repeat what he said too the
other cast members have been great you
know getting the real cast members in
the booth and the personalities and the
passion that they've brought to helping
us and working with us has been
fantastic so i will echo what bruce says
the fans will love everyone that we've
brought back for this it's gonna be
exciting well the fans are never
satisfied that's the first thing you
have to start with you'll get up to
about 80 satisfaction if you're if you
include absolutely everything and go
completely over the top you can get to
about 82 so that's kind of what we're
hoping for is that satisfaction but i i
do think fans will realize that we
we do think about them and we do factor
them in
yeah no as you said 80 percent uh in
this day and age of the internet it's
pretty damn good
looks like as you said a an awesome game
uh with sabre uh you know it feels very
up-to-date modern and sort of the
gameplay and the graphics and style but
such a classic franchise and i love that
it's got your official seal of approval
and you coming back to play all four
ashes so uh we cannot wait to jump in
next year to uh evil dead the game
thanks guys good play like the wind
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
yeah yeah
[Music]
get ready
[Music]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen boys and girls the
moment you've all been waiting for
the grand reopening of the circus
electric
this gifted group await their first
glorious night performing under the big
top
at least it was supposed to be
now they fight for their lives for a
madness suddenly enslaved the city not
letting go and it will take unique
talents like theirs
[Music]
tomorrow some stay behind to entertain
the show must go on after all
together
with the help of everyone we'll find a
way to end this chaos against any
challenge
[Music]
the circus electric
will step right up
you just saw world premiere trailers and
announcements for three new upcoming
titles coming from saber in 2022 dakar
desert rally is a legendary annual
off-road endurance racing event and is
shaping up to be the biggest open world
rally racing game ever made developed by
our talented and passionate saber portal
studio it's got rally cars bikes trucks
ssds all the authentic vehicles and
teams racing through giant sandstorms
desert dunes and mountains and we've got
racing modes for hardcore sim fans all
the way down to fans of arcade racers
look for more information about dakar
desert rally early next year redoubt 2
takes the racing genre to literally new
heights in development at our 34 big
things studio it's the next generation
sequel to the acclaimed anti-gravity
eraser red out if you're a fan of the
classics like wipeout and f-zero then
this is the game we've been waiting for
the reveal trailer shows just a glimpse
at its speed and style and we look
forward to sharing more with you soon
circus electric is a very special and
unique game
you may know zen studios from their
amazing pinball games including this
year's hit star wars pinball vr release
but they've also got quite a knack for
rpgs and this is their biggest rpg yet
set in an alternate victorian era
steampunk london where unknown forces
are turning ordinary citizens into
rampaging madmen
our hero amelia and a colorful cast of
circus performers from the circus
electrique need to get to the bottom of
this mystery and save the city when the
game launches next year and we hope you
enjoyed our chat with bruce campbell and
jeff keeley all about evil dead the game
we know you are excited to see and hear
more about the game so get ready because
early next year we are going to release
the next video in our gameplay series
all about playing as the evil candarian
beast
what we've just showcased for you are
the games coming from saber publishing
next year
now we have more to announce soon
but we're not quite ready so stay tuned
oh and if you saw the game awards last
night then you saw another world
premiere announcement and reveal trailer
that we're extremely proud of
developed by our very talented saber st
petersburg studio and published by our
friends at focus entertainment space
marine 2. it's an absolutely
action-packed next generation experience
from the cult classic space marine
franchise set in the games workshop
warhammer 40 000 universe you play as
the original space marine eight foot
tall superhumans who never back down and
never take cover you'll slice through
your enemies using your chain sword or
you'll tear them apart with your arsenal
of over-the-top powerful weapons
check out the reveal trailer
and thank you for watching
look for more information on all our
upcoming games from sabre in 2022
thank you
[Music]
it
so
so
[Applause]
[Music]
so
essentials
[Applause]
[Music]
you